air conditioning we certainly can't live
without it here in the valley 8 news now
reporter Brian will shows us how to keep
the AC unit running all summer long
last thing you want during this heat air
conditioning problems these guys tackle
it every day and during the summer
months they are going from call to call
the majority of the calls this time of
year are repair calls AC broke it's
blowing warm air it's not cooling it's
not coming on we wake up early in the
morning and we work 12 hours a day we
work eight to eight you know it's
basically until the phone stopped
ringing when you call they send someone
out to see what may be the issue one of
the many things technicians check when
they come out to see your AC is the
levels of refrigerant using this device
here
while some old ACS run on a refrigerant
called R22 it's being phased out and
newer units are switching to 410A Johnny
Freeman with Johnny on the spot AC says
it's been a target for thieves
contractor vehicles are always a target
for theft and refrigerant is one of
those things that that people will go
after we've had some experiences with
that in the past so it's definitely
something that that's happening you can
protect your AC unit by making sure it
is anchored to your concrete slab Freon
is very expensive so it really just
depends on on what you've got going on
what the issue is whether it's going to
be a bigger pair or a smaller pair this
AC Tech says to avoid future problems
with your unit schedule regular
maintenance and don't mess with that
thermostat try to maintain the
temperature at this you know at all
times don't try to fluctuate it
it is recommended to keep the thermostat
77 to 79 degrees and turn on those
ceiling fans Brian will 8 News Now
a rise in refrigerant thefts across the
country has led to the development of
more tamper resistant AC units along
with stiffer penalties intentionally
cutting a refrigerant line is a
violation of federal law regulated by
the EPA